Okay, let's prepare to look
at the actual methods.
You remember the textField should
change characters and range method.
Notice that the first
perimeter of the methods
in the textField delegate was
always the textField itself.
It will be the same in
the tableViews two protocols,
notice that the tableView method
has an argument named indexPath.
This is a struct with two members,
row and section.
By the way, for more on structs,
see the instructor notes or
peak ahead into the Swift
section in lesson five.
When the table wants to get the cell for
a particular row,
it invokes a method asking for
the cell and it passes in an indexPath
object with the row property set.
Similarly, when a table wants to alert
its delegate that a row was selected.
It invokes the appropriate method and
passes in an indexPath object
with the row property set.
Remember, we're interested in the
following three questions that the table
will ask.
How many rows?
What is the cell for each row?
And what should happen
when a cell is selected?
Which method signatures
corresponds to these questions?